- [Announcer] Five, four,
three, two, one, zero, ignition.
- [Narrator] In less than three years,
Space X has launched about 1800 satellites
to build a network called STARLINK.
- The world seems to have
an insatiable appetite
for bandwidth.
- [Narrator] STARLINK is
one of several projects
to bring super fast internet
to basically every corner of
the earth using satellites.
Its rivals include Britain based OneWeb
a nascent initiative by Amazon,
but also China's own satellite industry.
- The amount of traffic in space
and particularly in low earth orbit
has increased dramatically
largely due to the STARLINK.
- [Narrator] Now rivals and
countries are complaining
that STARLINK satellites have
endangered other spacecraft.
According to one tally
by a British university.
STARLINK is involved in as
many as 2,400 close encounters
every week, about 58% of
all such known incidents.
- Things have gotten
louder in recent times
as STARLINK is growing.
- [Narrator] After China
complain to the United Nations
that its space station had to maneuver
to avoid hitting a STARLINK satellite,
Musk responded that there's
plenty of space in orbit.
But as Space X alone
wants to launch tens of
thousands more satellites,
sciences and critics are
now raising safety concerns
and calling for more regulation in space.
To understand why STARLINK
has drawn so much criticism
first, you need to know
where the satellites are
and how they work.
- [Jonathan] Space X astronomy.
They're in low earth orbit.
- [Narrator] Jonathan
McDowell is a scientist
at the Harvard Smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics,
and he's been studying space
programs around the world
for over 40 years.
- The majority of the STARLINK satellites
are orbiting at their operational
height of 550 kilometers.
- [Narrator] And that's different
from the traditional broadband
satellites we had before,
which usually operate
about 36,000 kilometers
above the earth ground.
The closer distance allows
the STARLINK satellites
to more easily provide
faster internet speed.
But the flip side is.
- You need thousands instead
of like three or four
to cover the whole world
because a low orbit satellite
is gonna go overhead rise
above the horizon and set again
in just a few minutes.
- [Narrator] One issue is that low orbit
is already quite crowded.
There are other satellites
used for purposes
like monitoring weather or taking pictures
as well as older devices
launched since the 1950s
and also the International Space Station
and China's space station
are located in that area.
Not to mention tons of space debris
from leftovers from earlier
space missions and tests.
On top of that critics say
STARLINK's satellite's movements
are hard to predict
because of the particular
technology they use.
- They use what's called
electric propulsion.
STARLINK is the only large constellation
that's using electric
propulsion on a regular basis
in low earth orbit.
It fires all the time very slowly.
Gradually it's mood changing
its orbit all the time.
- [Narrator] OneWeb also
uses similar technology,
but it only has a few hundred satellites.
On the other hand, many satellites
use chemical rocket
engines to change course
only when needed.
And so most of the time
they sit in a fixed orbit.
So what are the actual risks
of an accident happening
in low orbit?
In its recent complaint
China detailed two instances
in which its space station found itself
in the way of STARLINK satellites.
- So this complaint kind
of mirrors the complaints
that have been made in the
past about similar incidents.
The European Union had a
complaint like that in 2019.
And then one year later OneWeb,
the British based constellation
has made a similar complaint.
- [Narrator] China didn't
call for specific action
by Space X, but said
countries are responsible
for what happens in space
under international treaties.
Space X didn't respond to
our request for comment
on these incidents, but
Musk has pushed back
in a recent interview
claiming that space is big
and there's room for tens
of billions of satellites.
STARLINK has said its
satellites are equipped
with artificial intelligence
to help avoid collisions,
but it hasn't revealed
details of the system.
- It's quite a large object.
And if something that big
hits you at that speed,
it's gonna completely
disintegrate your spacecraft.
And if it were to hit the
Chinese space station,
it would destroy it and
kill all the people aboard.
- [Narrator] Satellites must fly
at about 17,000 miles per
hour in low earth orbit,
which is roughly 250 times
faster than a car on the highway.
Although no collision has been reported,
such accidents could also be catastrophic
because of the chain reactions
they would potentially create,
which is illustrated in
this animated simulation
by the European Space Agency.
- [Jonathan] These
objects smashed together,
generate thousands of pieces of debris,
which then hit other objects,
which then carry more
thousands of pieces of debris.
- [Narrator] Scientists
say all these risks
need to be factored in by
everyone, not just STARLINK
and the fast-growing industry.
- STARLINK is the market
leader at the moment
and other companies
are trying to catch up.
So I don't think we will see the frequency
of launching these satellites subside.
- [Narrator] China
hasn't started launching
its own satellites, but has
plans to build a constellation
of more than 10,000.
Amazon's project KUIPER, which
is set to test satellites
in 2022 aims to build a
network of more than 3000.
And OneWeb, which is controlled
by Indian conglomerate,
Bharti global and the UK government
wants to send more than
600 satellites into space.
As all these satellites head to the skies,
the race sets the stage for global debate
about how to regulate them.
- One of the points that
that critics and scientists
are making is that this regulation
needs to become more
advanced and more uniform
in order for countries
to kind of work together
in the same framework.
- But unfortunately, that
process is a slow process,
much slower than the rate at
which commercial development
and technology development is going.
So I think it's actually a good sign
that China is engaging
in this in a public way,
presented to the UN
really puts the issue of
space traffic management
higher on the agenda.